i've stepped in to help with my greatest
asset my taste
kim kardashian starts some internet beef
it's so crazy over how she eats fake
meat it's a simple change that makes a
really big difference so fun here's the
backstory so kim just became beyond
meat's chief taste consultant aka
spokesperson for this new campaign
there's never been a better time to go
beyond
and while kim is chewing and holding
that burger in the ad fans quickly
pointed out she never takes an actual
bite of the food
and there's more fodder for conspiracy
talk where that came from because in
another part of the clip kim squeezes
lemon juice on tacos traditionally
topped with you know limes i've stepped
in to help with my greatest asset my
taste
she then takes a selfie holding her taco
which appears to be completely uneaten
you just gotta roll with it now we could
say this is just the passing of the
family food fail baton
yep because just last week her little
sis kendall jenner took some heat for
her very uncool approach to slicing a
cucumber i don't know i'm kind of scared
there you go
don't cucumbers have seeds
oh yeah they're definitely
i'm not a good cutter so don't zoom in
on me
i'm not professional whatsoever the
moment went down on the fam's new hulu
series i love that
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes and i
love that some of the journeys that all
of them are on and their different you
know passions and with the show giving
fans an inside peek at the kardashian
jenner fam's lives and very real moments
do you want um the chef to make you a
snack i'm making it myself just gotta
chop up some cucumber it's pretty
amazing
you go girl
be careful because i cut i nicked myself
the other day i don't know i'm kind of
scared there you go
don't cucumbers have seeds
oh yeah they're definitely
i'm not a good cutter so don't zoom in
on me
i'm not professional whatsoever
hey chef
do you want to cut this up for her i'll
do it mom it's fine we'll have to just
keep up with this crew for what's next
maybe not when it comes to food trends
though
[Music]
you